na ist brescia alles brennt bei euch
herzlich willkommen wir heute meine
lieben freund seiner neuen episode trägt
user hier heute auf einem kanal am
richtig sonntag an ich würde sagen wir
starten heute wieder mit den besten tik
tok haben
klicken
ja findet immer neueste freitag 15 uhr
lokals shop.de
dieses kissen hier lounge auf jeden fall
am 21.2 also diesem freitag an meinem
geburtstag um 15 uhr 1000 mal im luca -
shop.de jede bestellung bekommt eine
familie handsignierte autogrammkarte mit
dazu ich doch da hat keiner bock drauf
von da kann ich nicht empfehlen am
freitag um 15 uhr im shop vorbei zu
schauen und wir starten mit dem ersten
tik tok vom heutigen tik tok tuesday
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hab jetzt schon kein besonders schöner
tag
die wichtige partie vorher
no way
ich glaube das ist nutella und dörfler
judith beck gibt den gropius-bau was
habe ich mir gerade angeschaut
auch das ist wieder so ein
paradebeispiel dafür dass männer kürzer
leben als frauen
ok respekt dicker du hast dir nichts
gebrochen und muss nicht auf die fresse
geflogen
[Musik]
euro
in einigen punkten stimme ich sie auf
jeden fall über ein aber im großen und
ganzen vertrete ich doch eine andere
meinung alle freunde da ist man ja
stimmt mal ab hier oben schreibt sie
auch mal gerne die kommentare
ich
wann soll ich meinen kanal eigentlich
endlich mal löschen kammer bruder
einfach kam er verschwendet da essen
tritt auf eine paprika und tomate drauf
und auf eine zwiebel oder roger beck kam
ein kleiner so nicht deine familie hier
ist simon herbst nicht verordnet als
realistische preise sind der tag
verloren
das stufen wir machen weiter
[Musik]
ich finde diese dodge challengers immer
richtig süß wie auf der einen seite aber
auf der anderen seite denke ich mir der
ist er ist ein harter check der hund
gerade dass es nur so eine art challenge
ist oder denkt er wirklich gerade wenn
der besitzer so macht denkt der hund
dann vielleicht auch scheiße ich
irgendwas falsch gemacht
bundes sprechen halt nicht menschlich
sprache haben sie anfang der woche
gemacht
nee ich hab mir woche wollte vorgang
dass ich jetzt nein ja meine damen und
herren an der stelle würde ich gerne
eine kleine schweigeminute einlegen und
rest in peace aussprechen an alle
headphone user da draußen jetzt
wahrscheinlich keine ohren mehr haben
ok reicht auch wieder die letten einfach
mal das handy zerstören fündig dort ein
hallo herr villis
[Musik]
ich will mich wieder einblenden aber ich
kann dir auf jeden fall wärmstens
empfehlen sprachen lernen
und ich hatte mein freund dem haus
gebaut da und gut und hier gehts los auf
dem sitzbank auf das aller aller
winzigste tik tok dass ich hier gesehen
habe ich weiß nicht wie crack mein humor
ist dass ich so was so 40 finde aber
[Musik]
rumänien beschreibt das alles komplett
normal und sagt dann guck mal hier
du kannst dich hinstellen einfach runter
bis und vor allem der kumpel von
niemandem wo er einfach so ein eimer auf
den kopf du bist und wieder aber gut mal
schauen was sich diesmal fragt menschen
können hier kann die luft sehen das ist
richtig können für schritt ein wasser
sehen und wir menschen können ja was sie
keinen wir schildern luft sehen
du weißt schon dass es ziemlich
wahrscheinlich ist dass ein haircut
dinosaurier pässe drin ist ich will habe
ich mit mir diskutieren jetzt okay
oh mein gott herzinfarkt wann ist die
sandhofer damit rutschig
[Musik]
ich hätte dich umgebracht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
extrem extrem geil folge ticker heute
das nächste tik tok ist wieder ein video
das einen angeblich bewusstlos werden
lässt es hat mir in den letzten tick
tock tuesday folgen auch schon mal dass
er solche leute dabei waren die das auch
wirklich hingekriegt haben
allerdings braucht man für dieses video
hier kopfhörer das heißt sucht euch
jetzt eure airport falls ihr reich seit
und falls sie nicht reich sein dann holt
euch eure scheißtag mediamarkt kopfhörer
und ich warte hier kurz also holt eure
kopfhörer
ich kann schon mal kurz noch mal sagen
hier diese skizzen freitag 15 uhr kommt
ein job jede bestellung bekommt seine
autogrammkarten ich hoffe ihr habt jetzt
eure kopfhörer im handy denn wir schauen
uns das ganze jetzt gemeinsam mal an
[Musik]
okay ich habe auch keine kopfhörer drin
entschuldigen sie ist das ein verdammter
plastikstuhl
was ist denn mit euch allen
da kommt ihr klar wahrscheinlich von der
finanzierung der irgendwie jetzt
überhaupt instant
eine banane traum für mich menschen
nicht gesund ziemlich abstoßend
[Musik]